Does one always have to make intentions
regarding when you're about to fast? And
secondly,
the timing of the intentions. Can you
just say something a little bit about
that?
>> As far as the intention is concerned, as
I mentioned earlier, that intention is a
fur and a beloved prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said it's mentioned in
sunai book of fasting had number 2331.
Her beloved prophet said a person fast
not accepted if he does not make
intention in the previous night. That
means for all the further fasting
compulsory fasting making intention the
previous night is compulsory. It can be
any part of the previous night. It can
even be till as late as just before the
fud time. Any time of the night you can
make intention. A person can make an
intention in the beginning of Ramadan
and it can be valid for the full month
of Ramadan unless he breaks it. If he's
sick or if he's traveling then he has to
again make intention but one intention
is also sufficient. And many people
think they have a misconception that
verbally saying it aloud is a must which
is not a requirement. I don't have to
say verbally that I intend to fast
because my intention is a na from the
heart. For example, if I get up late in
the night,
much before fud time for fasting,
suppose my son
when we have got up to do a suhur late
in the night and my son asks me that why
have you got up? I will tell him because
we have to fast. It's already understood
the nia is there. I don't have to say
that I have got up to fast.
>> Mhm.
>> The nia is there. So nia is important.
near in the heart. You don't have to say
it with your tongue. That's what most of
the people think. And I don't know of
any hadith which says that the prophet
or the Sabbath ever said loudly that I
intend to fast. Intention is in the
heart. And one intention is sufficient
for the full month of Ramadan unless as
I said it's broken. But this is only for
the fur fast. For a voluntary fast which
is not a fur fast intention is not a fur
because there's hadith again mentioned
in sunai in the book of fasting hadith
number 2323 one is the prophet he tells
his wife that I want food to eat and the
wife said that there's no food to eat so
he said okay I'm fasting that means his
intention was not there before in the
previous night he made it on the spot he
abstained from before dawn but his
intention was afterwards in the morning.
So for the voluntary fast it's not
compulsive to be made early the previous
except if it's a very important
voluntary fast like the Ashurah the 10th
of Maharam Ashura or it can be the day
of Arafat it's preferable to make
intention before because that's very
important fast for all the other
voluntary fast it's not compulsory to be
made before previous night for the nia
there are other three things which are
very important one thing if it's by
force and if something is broken then it
can be forgiven or by error or by
forgetfulness. As Allah says in the
Quran in surah Nahel chapter number 16
verse number 106 that after a person has
believed
then if he does something of unbelief
does something of kuf except by force
that mean if he does by force even kuf
or shik Allah will forgive so if someone
forces a person to break the fast his ny
was in there he can be forgiven and
Allah says in surah bakar chapter number
two verse number 286 Six that oh Lord
please do not catch us please do not
hold us responsible when we er when we
make a mistake or when we forget. So if
a person in his forgetfulness breaks his
fast like has water, Allah will forgive
him. Or if because of a mistake, Allah
will forgive which we shall deal later
inshallah.